en medio de la emergencia por kobe 19
dos salvadoreñas crearon la academia de
ciclismo urbano para motivar a otras
mujeres a usar sus bicicletas en lugar
del transporte público
llegaron en su mayoría mujeres a
aprender a andar en bici y transportarse
de su casa al trabajo y pues conociendo
de que hay menos riesgo de contagio
las clases que imparte la academia son
anunciadas en redes sociales cuestan
tres dólares y son impartidas dentro de
un parque a fin de preparar a las
futuras ciclistas urbanas para su salida
a las calles
eso fue lo que más me llamó la atención
que es liderado por mujeres y ellas
siempre están verdad promoviendo el uso
de la bicicleta principalmente las
mujeres el hecho de salir usando la
bicicleta es una acción de respuesta
para cambiar esta cultura también
machista verdad y de violencia que
también hacia las mujeres es bastante
particular
ellas están decididas a tomar la
alternativa de la bicicleta al
transporte colectivo también para evitar
el acoso según naciones unidas en el
país más de la mitad de las usuarias de
este servicio han sufrido violencia
salir en bicicleta
justamente en un acto político y es
reivindicar también un derecho más de
las mujeres que a veces se ve
restringido precisamente por la
violencia que se ejerce contra nosotras
por la inseguridad
lo que en un principio fue un reto ahora
es una conquista más mujeres se están
tomando las calles y a fuerza de pedaleo
reclaman ser visibilizadas como usuarias
de la bicicleta y esperan ver florecer
una movilidad urbana
más inclusiva